today we're going to be speaking with dr
balan jalal who's a researcher at
harvard university and visiting
researcher at cambridge university one
of the world's leading experts on sleep
paralysis uh it's really great to have
you on i appreciate it oh i'm glad to be
here david
so
sleep sleep is such an interesting field
because it seems to me
it's difficult to study it without
affecting one's sleep in the sense that
many of the settings in which sleep is
studied like sleep labs for example are
very unnatural situations to do
something that most of us do every day
which is sleep sleep while being
observed sleep with electrodes on etc it
seems that it's difficult to get
great data for that reason can you talk
a little bit about that is that true
yeah yeah that's true i mean you know
bringing somebody into a sleep lab and
hooking them up with these electrodes
and things like that and having them
sleep in a sleep lab is obviously not as
you know
useful as as the home environment where
you naturally sleep and things like that
so i agree uh it is difficult but
nonetheless it's it's doable
but i agree you know we don't have that
uh so it's a bit of a tricky thing in
that way let's maybe start and talk a
little bit about sleep paralysis now
to some degree
in certain phases of sleep we are
paralyzed in the sense that we might be
dreaming of taking some physical action
and you aren't taking that physical
action in the real world you might be
punching someone in a dream but your
body is not going out and punching into
the air and that's a good thing when it
happens in the in the correct times is
that right
that's right david so each night we
cycle through these 90 state like 90
minute cycles of sleep and if you sleep
eight hours i hope you do then you have
like maybe four of these blocks and
during one of these stages you go
through something called rem sleep and
during rem sleep you have these bizarre
life like crisp dreams you know the ones
where you see yourself on the moon
wrestling with an alligator and then
having tea with the queen everything is
just messed up you know so during these
dreams you certainly don't want to act
these streams out and hurt your sleeping
partner so your brain essentially the
lower part of the brain paralyzes your
entire body
and so yeah you have this paralysis each
night you know that that you you go
through pretty much now when we talk
about sleep paralysis as as a phenomena
and condition
what we're really talking about is
outside of rem sleep the body remaining
paralyzed
well sleep paralysis is basically this
like so you're in this paralysis state
during this rem stage of sleep and then
suddenly parts of the brain that has to
do with sort of uh sort of wakefulness
centers of the brain cortical reason
regions they become prematurely
activated so you start waking up in a
way even though you're still paralyzed
in rem so it's a the synchrony to the
architecture of rem whereby your brain
suddenly switches so it's awake and
sleeping at the same uh you know in the
same way at the same time so you have
this clash of wakefulness and rem
paralysis occurring at the same time so
that what what sleep paralysis is how
common is that you know about 20 of the
population have experienced sleep
paralysis at least one time but then you
have maybe uh one or two percent that
have it more chronically so they will
have sleep paralysis you know
two or three times a day or a week or
you know five or six times a month so it
is really but at least one uh in in um
at least 20 percent have it have had it
in one you know at least once in their
life
is it is it a bad thing in the sense of
is it a condition that we that we are we
try to treat i guess is the question
right so if you have it just like a
regular person you have it you know once
or twice in your life and indeed it can
be scary i mean you wake up paralyzed
you think you might you know think
you're going to die perhaps and then
there's a ghost in your room because
typically you have you hallucinate
during these experiences
and so that is terrifying and
frightening but it's not you know
pathological in its own in its own right
right it's just you know scary and
things like that but if you have it
chronically it becomes a parasomnia you
know so it's a fearful
uh thing that keeps occurring in your
life and our research suggests if you
give this too much meaning and you say
this is a demon chasing me i'm being
possessed and things like that which can
occur in certain cultures well then
potentially it could even lead to things
like anxiety and maybe even trauma from
just you know being overwhelmed by by
these this paralysis and having these
you know scary
hallucinations let's talk a little bit
about
the dream component of sleep
there is so much literature going back
so long with different ideas about dream
meaning and dream interpretation
um there are
one side is it's completely random
there's no connection whatsoever between
dreams and what's happening in the real
world for you there's another side which
is no that the dreams are a direct
response to things that are taking place
in someone's life and there can be sort
of specific meaning assigned to them
let's start with maybe some of the
common dream tropes that a lot of people
report so like falling in a dream and
waking up before you hit the ground is a
very common theme
teeth falling out can be another common
one the idea that you're kind of running
or walking but it's almost like you're
in molasses like it's very very
difficult to move you know there's these
common themes that a lot of people seem
to experience so it seems like it would
follow that there must be some meaning
to those at least
absolutely there's a there's a pattern
right so let's take them one by one so
you mentioned the tooth falling out
um so that seems to be uh due to sort of
the so all of us right and at a certain
age when we're children have teeth
literally falling out of our mouth and
imagine this must be very anxiety
provoking so obviously you will lay down
memories of this fear and anxiety that
will remain with you
for many people the rest of their lives
but they can't really you know
pin down like why do i have this dream
why am i terrified of my dreams falling
out well there was a period in our life
where our teeth were you know loose and
we're literally falling out so
yeah so you you lay down these memories
and the memory parts of your brain and
then you will dream about them often
another very common dream is like being
late for an exam even though i mean
you're 40 50 60 you're running your
business but you're dreaming about being
late for an exam right so that's a
common one then you mentioned the
thing where you're trying to you know
run you know you can't get away what's
going on there well it turns out your re
your dream during rem sleep during this
dream stage of sleep have a has a
certain physiology and a certain neural
pattern
and one of these the signatures of this
is that your um the motor part of the
brain sort of the the this part of the
brain that has to do with movement is
sort of it's not fueled by the chemicals
it needs to move okay
and uh but the emotional part of the
brain is hyperactive that's a chemical i
see the choline and the emotional parts
of the brain are overactive so you have
this clash between your mortar part of
the brain the movement part of the brain
being weakened and then the emotional
part of the brain the instinctual part
of the brain being overactive and that
manifests as as this you this dream
where you are running but you are really
slow right you're in quicksand and then
this monster is chasing you so that is
an example
of that uh and what you mentioned
another one the falling one just falling
and waking up before you know before you
agree i think that's unclear but
probably because we used to drink or
sleep in high places right like trees
and things like that uh so it makes
sense to have reflex of you know being
able to catch yourself before you fall
so perhaps your brain has remnants of
this in its uh your memory centers but
you know in short
your brain has a certain chemistry
during the uh dream stage right so like
noradrenaline this chemical that allows
us to focus in on being really focused
is absent during the dream stage and
that means things are like spacey you
can't really focus on a specific thing
but it's more like the world is bizarre
and time is just and places are all
warped so that's a signature of that you
know or for example there's no logic or
a coherent story and that's because the
logical part of the brain is not working
so there is this neural signature that
defines what you then see but then you
have memories and things like that which
you will sort of pull in and sort of
color the dream so if you live in a
certain way you will dream about
monsters relevant to your culture so you
have all these elements in fact even
your environment if you're in a cold
room you might you know dream of being
in iceland and you know you know how
you're having a fight with a ice bear or
something you know like with a so so
certainly your environment your
physiology and all that influences your
dream in that way
there are so many um
academic texts and research now about
sleep problems and sleep problems are so
common particularly in in western
countries for sure
uh and there's so many different aspects
to this there's the hypnotic type
medications like ambien and lunesta that
some people take there's the sleep
hygiene aspect of you've gotta you know
get off screens at least an hour before
going to bed don't be doing things in
your bedroom other than sleeping
associate the bedroom with sleep you all
turn lights down there's kind of that
aspect of it there's the more kind of
like natural cures type side which often
involves
herbs or supplements or apple cider
vinegar and kind of all these different
things all of this different stuff
clearly because we recognize that sleep
is important and we do better when we've
slept well is there some kind of
overarching takeaways right now that you
think are the most important when it
comes to getting good sleep
it's a good it's a good question so i
would say sleep at the same time and
wake up at the same time every day your
brain has this biological clock that
really defines when you feel tired and
how you get quality sleep so that's one
thing the light issue is a huge thing
avoid bright light late in the night i
mean we know this but it's very
important to you know stick to this
um you know those are important to
remember stress and anxiety is the key
one i mean if you have stress and
anxiety during the day your brain just
can't turn off you know the emotional
parts of the brain will be overactive
and that will spill over into the you
know sleep state you know into sleep and
will just not allow you to have deep
quality sleep
so those are the main thing um so light
exercise is so easy just exercising
especially you can even do things like
walking you know that will help you get
more deep sleep the stage four before
rem sleep that that's important sort of
for you know growth and uh just cellular
repair and stuff like that so exercise
is a great one
you know i would say those are the main
pillars and also if you can sleep
consistently i mean we did some there's
some we did not but there's some studies
were done over in boston
uh david where they showed that if you
sleep a regular
amount of hours each night let's say
even six or seven that's better than
sleeping like eight nine and then six
and five and then eight and ten and so
having a regular you know amount of
sleep each night is better than just you
know going crazy on you know in the
weekends with like 12 hours there are
some people i mean famously donald trump
who says that for his whole life he's
basically only slept about four hours a
night and that that's enough that he
feels fine i know
including from matthew walker's research
that there is a range of what is sort of
like the natural correct amount of sleep
for people but i've not seen anything
empirical that suggests the that the
human body can function properly with an
extended period of four hours a night of
sleep can you talk about that at all are
there people who genuinely are fine with
that amount of sleep
you know i was surprised when i learned
there actually is so there's a genetic
you know mutation in a rare subset of
people so it's very rare it's probably
not you and i david unfortunately
certainly not me
but uh there is a rare breed of people
that can sleep four or five hours so you
know and they will feel rested and they
just sleep more efficiently they have
this mutation and perhaps you know in a
you know and enough time we'll all have
this mutation if it's if it's you know
advantageous but certainly there is uh
seems to be this genetic mutation of
people who sleep very little but i was
quite surprised when i learned that this
seems to be the case and there's some
folks in california doing research on
this uh very curious topic yes but it
but it is seems to be true have you
studied a lot or or read a lot about the
idea of the the biphasic sleep schedule
there's this idea that back when we had
to stoke fires in the middle of the
night
um humans would you know sleep three or
four hours be up for an hour or two and
then sleep another three or four hours
and it seems to be the sort of a source
of a lot of debate because on the one
hand
it does appear as though there was a
point at which it would have made sense
based on circumstances but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's a good or
healthy thing to be doing right
i think that research on this is
emerging uh there it could be that
biphasic sleep in the way you mentioned
i mean certainly people used to many
people used to sleep like that you know
with their rituals at night and then go
going back to sleep
and it seems like it could potentially
be good that you get more efficient
sleep in that way but the research i
would say is emerging uh another you
know just uh element to this is also the
whole idea of a siesta time and sleeping
uh during that time and it seems also
there might be a biological
advantage of of of doing that the fact
that you will feel tired by noon and
sleeping for those hours could
potentially help and even napping can be
very very refreshing and you know
sometimes even compensate for hours of
sleep but i think the research on that
at least for my knowledge is 100 clear
and certainly not with the biphasic
sleep but i wouldn't i wouldn't rule it
out it could be that it's it's you get
more you know for your no more bang for
the buck by sleeping in that way it
could be when you've talked about kind
of like the natural sleep schedules of
people there's quite a bit of research
that throughout our lives the natural
wakefulness and sleepiness schedule kind
of shifts and one of the big areas of
controversy with this is the time that
school starts for different kids
and when i was in high school the first
class started at 7 35 a.m
which was completely counter to my
natural schedule which was to be up
until 12 30 or one in the morning now i
get up far earlier that's a schedule
that now now would work much better for
me is there something to this idea that
much school is starting way too early
absolutely so there's a genetic
component to when you want to fall
asleep you know like there's a chrono
type in terms of like we have our
genetic uh you know preference in terms
of when we want to sleep and want to you
know whether you want to be night owls
or or not and uh so yes for a lot of
people they will just naturally be night
owls they will be inclined to sleep very
late and wake up later and so for those
folks it's it's a problem because you're
you're starting school that early and
you will exclude these people in that
way you won't have their full uh you
know brain capacity uh you know you'd be
using that so so it is something but
i'll say something i you know in my
entire life david i was i was sleeping
maybe at two or three a.m that's just my
natural thing but the last four years
i've been sleeping at 10 p.m you know so
i've totally shifted how i sleep as well
and it just works better so sometimes
even though you think you're a night owl
by nature you might in fact be somebody
who's not so no me too i mean i i tried
i also saw this natural shift where
because of my schedule 10 15 and i was
just getting into bed and i thought to
myself i used to kind of be a night owl
let me see what happens if i try to just
stay up a little later and get up a
little later it felt very unnatural
where i was just fine it was a you know
11
and i was just like i i should just be
in bed right now this this doesn't feel
like it's my schedule any longer
100 that's what happened to me and i was
surprised and i was i thought i was
genetically just you know doomed to be
somebody who has you know sleep at 3 a.m
but yeah you know i sleep much earlier
and i feel better the the work in the
field is fascinating we've been speaking
with dr balan jalal who's a researcher
at harvard university and also a
visiting researcher at cambridge
university really a pleasure having you
on and i appreciate your time today
my pleasure david